[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to the arena
where on this day we honor the memory
of the drum major
i'm ernie johnson grateful to be here to
host an hour-long round table discussion
which will begin in just a few minutes
from the pulpit of ebenezer baptist
church here in atlanta shortly before
his death
dr martin luther king jr told the
congregation that he wanted to be
remembered as a servant and as a drum
major for justice for peace
for righteousness
we will reflect on his legacy today
but we begin with a visit to memphis
for years on this day on our show we've
spoken of the national civil rights
museum and i always found myself saying
you know i need to get there and see it
for myself
well last week i did
my wife cheryl and i found ourselves
wading into a sea of history
taking photographs
immersed in the stories of heroes
upon heroes
there are
inside the walls of the national civil
rights museum in memphis
chapters of the civil rights struggle
painful to the core at the same time
figures in bronze
stand as witness to courage
and resolve
faces of determination molded and cast
hearkening back to a time when they were
moved to action
and now they stand immovable
serving as testament to the solidarity
and sacrifice it took to enact change
far too long in coming
inside these walls there are stories so
many stories
i was introduced to clara looper
the oklahoma high school teacher who
organized lunch counter sit-ins
who was arrested two dozen times
who took her father's lifelong
frustration at being denied the right to
sit at a restaurant of his choosing and
said
tonight is the night
history compels us to go
let history alone be our final judge
ernest greene
one of the little rock nine
who enrolled at all white central high
and was the first to graduate
despite a written plea from a white
worried senior did he not attend the
ceremony
you deserve your sheepskin as much as
anyone else and i would not stop you
from getting it however there are
as you well know many who would gladly
do so
it will be a time that i and hundreds of
others do not wish to have marred
there is joanne robinson an english
professor at alabama state college who
on the day rosa parks was arrested for
not surrendering her seat on a
montgomery alabama bus went to an office
at the college and secretly mimeographed
thousands of flyers calling for a
one-day bus boycott
and distributed them throughout the city
you read words from the younger brother
of medgar evers hands that pick cotton
can now pick the mayor
as charles evers became the first
african-american mayor of a southern
city
since the days of reconstruction
ultimately your journey in memphis so
powerful
takes you to room 306 at the lorraine
motel
and while you know the story of april
4th 1968
there is this feeling
wish i could articulate it
i can't
of seeing that room and that balcony and
that boarding house across the street
where it is believed the shot was fired
that took the life of dr martin luther
king jr
and there is this
just moments before the deadly shot rang
out dr king
standing on the balcony
had been in conversation with
saxophonist ben branch on street level
he asked if branch would play his
favorite hymn precious lord take my hand
in an upcoming rally
and quote play it real pretty
branch's response we are told was
you know i will doc
there was so much to take in so much to
process in this visit it's overwhelming
and then as you make your way toward the
exit you see the work of sculptor
michael pavlovsky the movement to
overcome it stands in the museum's
atrium and encapsulates what you've just
spent hours experiencing a tribute to
the millions who have marched
who have struggled
who have climbed
ever upward